Kabul is on the brink what do you say
Ray Kabul is on the brink look it's been
I don't understand it's been 20 years
since 9 11. are we really still worried
about them doing terrorism I mean look
if they're not morons and they learn
their lesson like hey it took us 20
years to get this back maybe we don't
have the next Bin Laden hanging out over
here but they didn't really
well they took the country over but if I
was Taliban I'd be like look the one
thing we don't do is have terrorist
camps that's right in Taliban that's
what I would do because now we're back
in charge they can't look but then they
tell me it's gonna be like but they're
telling us the US is telling us
yeah they're telling us
don't fall for it
don't grade point don't fall for it you
fell for it in the 80s you kept falling
for it through the 90s like when we tell
you we want to train an arm radical
elements of your Society don't go in for
that
I mean has there ever been a country
maybe I don't want to like play a
typical you know uh whatever but you
know France it gets accused of laying
down for the Nazis but like I'm saying
Afghanistan they don't they don't seem
to be doing anything at least all the
American officials are saying like we
trained them like we like we did all
this they're not doing anything to stop
this the Afghan you know provisional
government whatever they call it a
regular government or the Armed Forces
of I mean we've been training them for
20 years at what point are we like you
know yeah you got to defend your own
country
I mean it's a great Point Michael Tracy
said on Twitter it's like how have we
built this thing that collapses in like
a day
how does this work maybe maybe we were
just spending the whole West 20 years
like growing opium
I also don't think we ever want any of
this to work yeah
well we we want a reason to go back
yeah well we wanted to collapse I mean
maybe that's the thing maybe that's the
play is that like look we're gonna look
we're gonna go back but we need a year
or two where it gets real bad we're like
we can point to like look they're making
the women wear dog collars again we
can't allow this like you know it was
too good for too long in Afghanistan
yeah
it's very strange and I don't know
what's gonna go down I just know that
we've got really a few peaceful years
left on this planet before it gets a
hell of a lot worse
um and uh I just it's tough to tell
people that served the country
like the people that are joining the
military now say God bless them
I mean it's still better than working at
Walmart I guess I guess you're right
that's a good point
he's not getting a job at Ford
right
yeah I mean it's it's because now
there's we now know
like it's the proof is really out there
that like nothing is is gonna work no I
mean like
sure
should the Armed Forces now just have a
sign that says you will die in vain
like there's I mean no way
there's no way you won't dive in unless
somehow like you save a bay on one of
these missions that makes sense to no
one that's doomed to failure maybe you
like save a baby and that's your good
but pretty much or you're Chris Kyle and
you shoot the baby right
dude so Ben Ben uh
goes out you know they have friends in
Texas and like all the people here in
Texas think Chris cosica here like they
they like they believe like everything
you know like they're just like they're
like you ever seen a movie American
Snapper
you ever see it
you ever see that movie you're a Dark
Thirty
what it's a clown show it's a it's uh
they'll hate they'll hate Jesse Ventura
I think he's a an American scum
yeah so what was that right
Chris Kyle basically in his book said
that Jesse Ventura was like SM seal
funeral Navy SEAL funeral and just like
saying the guy deserved to die
like I got some fight with him and like
which is like even look I know he goes
on TV and talking about the Loch Ness
monster but I mean the guy was like
basically a seal like I don't think he's
like Jesse Ventura alive or dead oh he's
alive okay yeah he's an interesting guy
to get on the show oh he'd be great to
talk to
yeah I mean you know I mean look just
don't ask about the harp gun he goes he
gets a little uh I think he's got a
little hazy when you when you talk about
stuff like that but why I think he knows
he's just like he doesn't really have a
I I he casts a wide net what the weather
gun is that what you mean by the harp
gun I'm just saying he's gonna have a
strong filter I think he wanted to fill
that show up but like you know topic so
it's a good points about about 9 11 and
some other weird [ __ ] no he does yeah so
I'm saying it's just you know but then
he might start going off but the harp
gun is the real problem there is a
covered God you feel like Jesse
stay focused I take Ivermectin in my
[ __ ]
it's not gay
it's just going off about Navy Seals
Navy Seals are all deserve deserve what
they get Shield team six with a bunch of
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
Bin Laden's an American [ __ ] hero
what how great would it be if he just
went completely insane
I love Osama Bin Laden and the bin Laden
family
yeah the only God is Allah the only true
God is Allah
he should open up we we should like
we should we should see how far we can
get telling him we're like big investors
and that we want to open up a conspiracy
theory restaurant with him
conspiracy Fridays you'd get a meeting
like you'd absolutely get a meeting if
like you were like Jesse we really want
to open up like a conspiracy theory
conspiracy themed restaurant like an
Applebee's or a Fridays or an Outback
you know but instead of like boomerangs
and kangaroos on the wall we have like
syringes pictures of building seven and
[ __ ] like you know
the Northwoods nachos are my favorite
like things like that
MK Ultra Feast yes okay all true
I mean we I always wanted to do a
conspiracy theory line ice creams we
talked about it on the patreon but ice
cream it was so hard you can can't do it
you can't ship it you can't make any
money I've always wanted to make my own
line of ice cream
the conspiracy hot sauce maybe no I'm
sick of the sauces I can't taste
anything right now food is still good
which is how you know that like you you
have a problem with food is it when you
can't taste anything food's like still
you're still looking forward to it
people like how can you eat I'm like you
just don't taste it you just keep eating
chewy I'm eating a lot healthier now I'm
just eating nothing inflammatory because
of the covered which I think in a few
days I'll test negative
um
but the uh what you may call it the um
yeah I've always wanted to make a line
of ice creams and sell them but it's
very expensive
to a very small select group of people
like we have to literally we probably
have to charge something stupid for a
pint of ice cream
50 bucks something like that people
might buy it you gotta I think you're
right
well you had a great like we had some
good ideas about like Jeffrey egg cream
where we'd have like we'd have like an
egg cream style ice cream with like
um like uh a fudge Ripple and then like
little chocolate girls
or we'd have like the uh sweet
um jet fuel doesn't melt sweet cream
and we'd have like a 911 themed ice
cream like we you know we had a whole
thing controlled demo licorice something
like that Joan beignet Ramsey which had
Beignets and it had a chicory coffee
swirl it was a New Orlean theme even
though they're not from there but
you know